SPEAKER 1: Aristotle
writes, this alone
is denied even to God to make
what has been not to have been.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So first of all,
why study history?
It comes from a Greek word means
inquiry, looking into things.
The first book of history
was written by Herodotus.
It's called The Histories.
It's a story of the past.
And of course, not
everything in the past--
significant things in the past,
things that we can learn from,
things that stand for something.
It's just a piece,
really, of this wish
that we have to understand.
In his Metaphysics, Aristotle
says in the first line,
the human soul stretches
itself out to know.
We like to know.
And one of the things
we like to know
is we like to know
about ourselves
because, unlike other
creatures, we're
not ruled simply by instinct.
We have to choose our way--
which way should we go?
And then the second thing
is we look at others.
And we are unusually
well-equipped to do this
because we can talk.
We can explain
things to each other.
We can tell each other about
our innermost thoughts.
So history just
expands the scope.
And the past is the only
thing we can study intensely.
The present is fleeting.
Past is fixed, at
least according
to the old school of thought.
These days, it's a
deconstructionist age,
and what we think is we're our
own special time, a development
or a progress on previous times.
And that sets up a way to
reinterpret those old times so
that they fit our categories.
And we tend to look
down on them a bit, too.
And that seems to
me exactly wrong.
Aristotle writes, this
alone is denied even to god
to make what has been
not to have been.
So history-- it
gives us a fixity
that is made up of
things that at the time
were constantly shifting
and hard to estimate.
When we're picking
what we're going
to do from among
various options,
we always have two
things in mind.
One is, what would be
the right thing to do.
And the other is, what
is it possible to do?
And you can't always do
the purely right thing.
Well, if you go back and
study the people in the past,
they're in the same situation.
And yet, in their case,
the whole story is known.
It's not changing anymore.
And you can go back,
and you can put yourself
in the shoes of
Winston Churchill
or of Abraham Lincoln--
those, by the way,
are two things
that are sublime to
do, beautiful to do,
important to do.
And you can be with them where
Lincoln faces the question,
should I let the South go?
Look at the body count.
Lincoln grappled
with that question.
You can grapple with him.
Churchill-- should we fight
to the death against Hitler?
He's offering a deal.
So the point is,
there's a lot to know.
And what can you know?
Can you know it's
now right or wrong
to do what we're going
to do in some country
where we've had wars?
No, you can just know
that a serious man
had caution about that.
And what were the
factors that he
evaluated to make up his mind?
You could look at
the same factors--
they may be different today.
But all of that depends
on treating history
as if it is made by people who,
although very different from us
in many ways, are
yet still people--
the animals that can
talk to each other,
learn from each other, recognize
good and evil, which are all,
by the way--
we have of course on Aristotle
where we explain this--
those are all related.
Our ability to see good and
evil and our ability to talk
boil down to the same thing.
And so a creature
like that which
lives in a perishable
body and has needs--
how does it steer itself
by the ultimate truth
when, in its needs, it's
just like any animal?
Well, that's the human test.
And the people in the past
had to go through that test.
Good history, then,
will be an accurate,
insofar as it's humanly
possible to make it,
picture of what
happened in the past,
with a sympathy
for the people so
that one can learn from them.
They made mistakes, yeah.
And don't we?
Do we live in a
perfect world today?
If we don't, then they were
grappling with the same thing
we are.
SPEAKER 2: Thank
you for watching.
We hope you're enjoying
our Highlights series
and invite you to explore
all of Hillsdale College's
online courses.
They are free and for
everyone who loves to learn.